welcome to this video playing it not
expect from the US one of the opponent's
that I play four years here very low
rating enforcer standards it's been much
higher usually round two for something
okay I'm ready it's played with Bishop
g4 NC successes one of the most solid
waste to play can very much be
recommended to black players who just
want a solid position yeah I try to keep
pieces on here and maybe play a form
under favorable hopefully favorable
circumstances okay there may be here and
then you form it takes e4 should be
quite nice actually with the bishops and
well after seat XD i also have the
bishops but it's more of a symmetrical
position yeah this are already like for
what it's the bishop pair enter i have
this additional porn in the center it's
not like it's not like a cleared or
something but i like the type of
position very much long-term you you
always oh this is interesting yeah maybe
because he wants to go on lagi for
immediately other than that it wouldn't
make any sense okay let's still
recapture
if he goes Knight g4 I probably have to
play and who gave one which is not ideal
but next move I'm going to kick in with
h3 anyway maybe do I have something else
some other way to to play probably not
but it's not it's not a big problem it
looks passive but I play I play I kick
this night out anyway maybe with f 39
probably not a good idea but Bishop f4
d5 this could be an idea this night is a
bit vulnerable anyway being only
supported by his colleague on f6 yeah he
doesn't have any entry square this is
very important so Bishop f4 or not Jeff
why not it's not so badly placed there
and threatening a five if he goes h5 I
go h3 with a very nice position needs to
go to h6 then looks looks completely
completely crazy
maybe bishop how interesting yeah i was
thinking about Bishop d6 but of course
why not well this is certainly playable
so look d 1 yeah come on rook d1
the question is am i threatening rook
takes a t5 and maybe what I am
threatening is H 395 rook takes d4 this
is this is really a threat if he goes to
e5 now it's very difficult for black
analyst position interesting but I don't
think it's helping and much maybe just
go back this is probably good keeping
pieces on the board and still I've got a
ch3 now if I phone yeah okay so he's
going to go to e5 if I am I could go for
full expansion now first first go here
this is a good prep booth the idea is to
play not h3 and f4 but f-for first and
get out of Bishop b6 check ok so our
form threatening a five now
maybe he's got booked xt2 now he's got
very very cute position of the night on
age 6 I know if I've gives up a square
but I want I assembly get the pawn and
take the spawn getting something solid
okay take and yeah why not it's the
easiest I guess just exchange now it's a
I've won the spawn and still I have from
the bishop pal okay look here yeah like
to like to cover that
maybe Bishop g4 okay night to deform I
have worked it too though it doesn't
really I can I can play this first
awesome
oh he's allowing me to trade one book
this is of course who are coming his his
remaining rook is the passive room this
is why I don't mind that at all ok let's
go back with the bishop you can take it
but i'll have the default if he does
sell this is also not bad so before or
not is got rooked the aid ok I better
get out of c-4 with the temple ok how to
how to play this now I can just maybe
advancium f6 I don't I do believe that
this is too much of a problem I wonder
about a body move like a form actually
ok but let's move get moving first maybe
just here at age 5 could be it could be
an easy solution
roop t2 yeah I need to make sure that
this isn't a big problem maybe just just
drop back the bishops control very
useful squares
check yeah this is a very very
uncomfortable pin ruku age 7 rook age 6
check and also check this one check
check time war jack there's no checkmate
somewhere check check I didn't find one
but the new queen is also fine check
checkmate yeah this was a fantastic
position I right out of the opening and
he never really recovered from that this
the combination of having this
additional Center porn and and the two
bishops this can be can be deadly if you
if you play on your hand right and I
think I'm here right at the beginning he
needs to improve some how to make it at
least playable position this I'm not
sure around here it gets very very
tricky already this five threat winning
the piece is really am a problem
computer wants to go rook to g8 to play
g5 they are not a very human here look
81 so good and now the computer just
wants to take me five a player for you
yeah this is a simple solution but I
wanted to keep the pressure on and I
still like this in this position and the
solution i mean yeah he needs to play
rook takes the 2 this is what I quickly
mentioned in the in the video this is a
thing the way to check to relieve some
pressure
I'm still somewhat better mostly because
my king is right in the action and I
have this mobile phones but this is the
drawback of playing and playing at four
I should probably play an h3 first but
the way it it was played it was it was
fantastic after that it's it's probably
just a win at least with with decent
technical play rook d7 was even stronger
okay but I think I always kept my pledge
so quite quite okay yeah thanks for
watching